okay so in this video we're going to
discuss retroviruses so let's go ahead
and get started you know as far as
viruses go there are several different
categories and types of viruses but
retroviruses are a specific type of RNA
virus and what makes them so unique is
that they possess an enzyme by the name
of reverse transcriptase typically if
you if you look at molecules and if a
molecule ends with the letters ASE it's
some kind of enzyme and that's what
reverse transcriptase is now in the
named reverse transcriptase you know
reverse means to go backwards and when
you hear the word transcriptase perhaps
you think of the process of
transcription so when we get into this
video in a little bit what you're going
to see is the process of transcription
going backwards that'll be more clear
when we get further into the video so in
my picture here there is this red circle
labeled reverse transcriptase and
there's other enzymes in the retrovirus
as well one very important enzyme is a
enzyme called integrase and you'll
understand why it's called integrase
later notice how there's also an outer
envelope that surrounds the entire
retrovirus and also an inner capsid that
surrounds the nucleic acid and the
enzymes but what we're going to do is
we're going to look at the steps that a
retrovirus goes through in order to
replicate so you have the key in the
upper left hand corner so you know what
everything is in my animation so what
how this process begins is the
retrovirus will attach and then enter
into the host cell so here comes our
retrovirus and it's just attached to the
cell membrane of the host the outer
envelope of the retrovirus is a lipid by
a phospholipid bilayer so the to fuse
together and as they fuse together the
retrovirus is taken into the host cell
well now which have not watch
what happens to the yellow capsid the
yellow capsid is dissolved and begins to
break down
this releases the enzymes of the
retrovirus and the RNA nucleic acid of
the retrovirus so the next step is going
to be the process of reverse
transcription now normally when I hear
the word transcription I think of this a
DNA molecule is used to create an RNA
molecule
however retroviruses because they have
that enzyme called reverse transcriptase
are able to perform transcription in
reverse reverse transcriptase will
actually bind to the virus RNA and
perform reverse transcription the viral
RNA will be used to build a molecule of
viral DNA and eventually the enzyme
reverse transcriptase is degraded and
broken down but more importantly the
retrovirus has created viral DNA for
itself and you're going to see why
that's important right now so as we move
on to the next step the DNA of the virus
that was just created will actually
enter into the nucleus along with the
enzyme called integrates now there's a
reason I've drawn integrase to kind of
look like a pair of scissors here to be
symbolic of what it performs integrase
will actually cut open the DNA of the
host cell and it's called integrase
because it helps to integrate the DNA of
the virus into the DNA of the host cell
that's why it's called integrase and
what this creates is this combination of
host cell DNA and viral DNA that is
known as a pro virus and so now when we
look at the next step viral RNA will be
created each time the host cell
transcribes its DNA so inside the host
cell our enzyme
that will direct the normal process of
transcription which is a using DNA to
make a molecule of RNA so in the nucleus
here is an enzyme that the cell
possesses and it will do normal
transcription notice what it did though
it made a copy of not cell RNA it made a
copy of viral RNA and so this happens
many many times and here we have another
copy of viral RNA being created and I
think I have five of them in my
animation so there's a third one and
here's a fourth copy of viral RNA being
made and lastly a fifth copy of viral
RNA being made through the normal
transcription process and so now what
happens is we're going to see the
purpose of making all this viral RNA
keep in mind in the cytoplasm of a cell
cells possess ribosomes now they possess
many ribosomes I'm just showing one here
for simplicity so what happens is the
viral RNA attaches to a ribosome and
through the process of translation the
ribosome will read the viral RNA and
create viral proteins viral proteins
such as reverse transcriptase as the
process of as this process continues the
ribosome will continue to read other
viral RNAs and create integrase the
viral protein called integrase and so if
you see what's happening the cells own
ribosomes are creating parts for new
viruses and as this process continues
the ribosome also creates the capsid of
a virus the capsid of a virus is simply
made from protein and that's what the
ribosome builds the ribosome builds
proteins it just so happens that the
proteins belong to viruses instead of
important parts needed by our cells to
survive
and so eventually these viral proteins
that the cells own ribosome created will
self assemble into immature viruses so
here we have the viral proteins self
assembling into retroviruses into new
immature retroviruses and eventually
these these immature viruses are
released through the cell membrane so
notice how the cell membrane has began
to bud out and as the process continues
the cell membrane continues to butt out
and bulge out until eventually there you
go a retrovirus has been released now
the same thing will happen with the
other two retroviruses in the cell but
this is how new viruses are created that
will then be released to repeat the
cycle eventually these immature viruses
will go through a series of of chemical
changes to become mature but then
they'll be able to repeat the cycle and
infect other cells if we finish this
video with a quick summary of what we've
learned here's a retrovirus entering its
genetic material into a host cell and
then the the process of reverse
transcription is performed to make DNA
of the of the retrovirus that viral DNA
is then integrated into the the host
cell's DNA into the genome of the host
cell this process will then direct the
duplication in the creation of a whole
bunch of viral RNA and viral proteins
the viral RNA and proteins will self
assemble into new retroviruses that will
be released so this is the cycle of how
a retrovirus replicates I hope you found
this video helpful and thank you for
watching and place your comments in the
box below I'd like to hear what you
think